esta es la ceremonia central oficial de
alemania para honrar a esas 80.000
personas que en el último año murieron
por cuenta del hobbit 19 es una
ceremonia organizada primordialmente por
el presidente esta imagen es el jefe de
estado aquí en alemania style maya ya
había dado indicaciones a principios de
año que quería tener una ceremonia como
tal en el discurso central que ofreció
en berlín time mañana seguro que era un
momento para alemania para brindar
solidaridad para pensar en esas personas
que fallecieron y en las que los
parientes que hoy todavía sufren por
cuenta del cobi 19 explicó que es un
momento para dejar atrás las
estadísticas las disputas políticas los
números de infectados y demás y de
verdad enfocarse en las personas que
están sufriendo por eso y también las
personas que están ayudando a las
personas están malla hizo énfasis
también en que ese es un momento para
honrar y darles las gracias por ejemplo
las personas que trabajan en hospitales
y en cuidados intensivos es una
ceremonia muy importante para alemania
pues si bien el país
no ha sido tan afectado como otros
países del mundo cuando se miran las
estadísticas de fallecidos alemania
actualmente está en una situación muy
difícil por cuenta de la tercera ola de
la pandemia
bueno tomasa a propósito de eso hablemos
de las cifras dice estén mal que no es
el momento para hablar de eso pero es
importante recapitular cómo va la lucha
contra la pandemia
alemania actualmente se encuentra en un
momento muy difícil con cifras
crecientes en el número de infectados
con una situación particularmente
difícil en cuidados intensivos con camas
cada vez menores o cada vez menos camas
disponibles para cuidados intensivos con
cifras de verdad muy altas y además con
una disputa política sobre cuál es el
momento adecuado para tomar nuevas
decisiones y angela merkel tomó la
decisión en las últimas semanas en los
últimos días de tomar las riendas de la
política pues aquí había un popurrí muy
complejo de medidas dependiendo de cada
región y de cada lugar que incluso había
llevado que la mayoría de los alemanes
alguna encuesta admitiera que no sabían
qué medidas aplicaban donde entonces
esto explica la dificultad aquí en
alemania para controlar esta tercera ola
de la pandemia